now on to Washington some major
Revelations on the January 6 attack
former Republican Congressman that's
Denver riggleman a former adviser to the
January 6 committee told 60 Minutes Bill
Whitaker last night about possible
evidence and a connection to the Trump
White House that we have never seen
before Scott McFarland is on Capitol
Hill with more on that part of the story
Scott good morning it's very interesting
conversation last night it sure was Gail
good morning the January 6th select
committee is promising New Revelations
at its hearing Wednesday but this comes
as its former investigator makes strong
allegations of an attempted coup on the
sixth the committee members have been
pushed back against any specific
allegation but they say he's been gone
half a year and doesn't know the current
status of the investigation
just two days out from the next January
6th Committee hearing former committee
investigator Denver riggleman has
revealed this do you get a real aha
moment when you see that the White House
switchboard had connected to a rioter's
phone while it's happening that's a big
pretty big aha moment you get aha wait a
minute
someone in the White House was calling
one of the rioters while the riot was
going on on January 6th absolutely and
you know who both ends of that call I
only know one end of that call I don't
know the White House end riggleman says
his team collected a tidal wave of
thousands of texts and calls from Trump
supporters on and ahead of January 6th
but only got a fraction of the funding
he requested to look into the data
members of the panel pushed back that's
one of thousands of details that
obviously the committee is aware of
arguing riggleman a one-time Republican
Congressman Departed the committee staff
in April and has limited knowledge of
the panel's investigation and without
the advantage of the additional
information we've gathered since he left
the committee you know it it I think
poses real risk to be suggesting things
this weekend members of the committee
also leveled criticism at the Department
of Justice for the pace of its
investigation and for asking the
committee for its records my first
reaction when we got the request turned
over all your files to us was why don't
you have your your own damn files you
know why haven't you been conducting
your own investigation
committee Vice chair Liz Cheney says the
panel has received hundreds of thousands
of pages of secret service
Communications During the period around
January 6th that agency's role during
key events could be a key part of
Wednesday's Committee hearing Gail
this book is very interesting thank you
very much Scott in our next hour former
Congressman riggleman will join us here
at the table live to talk about the
evidence that he saw while working on
the January 6 investigation